es ist eine eigentlich unmögliche
entdeckung einen so alten stern dürfte
es gar nicht geben aber es gibt ihn ein
us astronomenteam hat wohl einen der
ältesten sterne überhaupt in unseren
kosmos entdeckt und dieser 13,5
milliarden jahre altes werk entstand
wohl nicht nur aus der ersten sternen
generation nach dem urknall sondern
liegt sogar direkt in der kosmischen
nachbarschaft unserer erde warum das
eine unmögliche entdeckung ist erfahrt
ihr jetzt mal klingt zum tanzen fitschen
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonnieren den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
los geht's rang
[Musik]
am anfang war der urknall ein unendlich
kleiner punkt aus dem alles entstanden
ist mit der zeit bildeten sich die
ersten atome moleküle sterne entstanden
planeten und galaxien
doch die ersten sterne dieser generation
müssten eigentlich längst ausgebrannt
sein doch bei diesem exemplar ist das
anders und das stellt die bisherigen
erkenntnisse der frühen sternentstehung
auf den kopf auf die schliche gekommen
ist das forschungsteam der university of
baltimore dem uralt stern mit hilfe des
gemini south teleskops und des magellan
telescope in chile
der rote zwerg befindet sich in
doppelsternsystem den unaussprechlichen
namen haben wir jetzt unten eingeblendet
das sind ein bisschen viele zahlen drin
direkt neben einem großen stern der
astronomie teams schon vor einiger zeit
aufgefallen war
und zwar weil dieser sehr arm an
schweren elementen ist bei sternen ein
hinweis auf ein extrem hohes alter
doch jetzt gelang es den kleineren der
beiden sterne den roten zwerg genauer zu
analysieren und das ist wirklich
verrückt er ist sehr klein verfügt über
etwa 14 prozent der sonnenmasse und ist
extrem arm an schweren elementen also
noch ärmer als der größere sternensystem
und damit gehört wohl zu den metall
ärmsten sternen überhaupt im gesamten
kosmos
das alles konnte durch sein
lichtspektrum ermittelt werden das
forschungsteam selbst ist total
überrascht von dieser entdeckung denn
nach ihrer einschätzung könnte der roten
zwerg ein stolzes alter von eben 13,5
milliarden jahren haben so liegt die
vermutung nahe dass der uralt stern
direkt aus der aller ersten generation
von sternen nach dem urknall entstanden
ist und diese erkenntnis stellt unsere
bisherigen vorstellungen über das alter
und die entstehung unserer galerie
sie infrage denn gängigen theorien
zufolge sind sterne die so kurz nach dem
urknall entstanden sind eher kurzlebig
und könnten demnach keinesfalls eine
solche lange zeit bis heute überdauern
die genaue analyse des runden zwerg ist
widerlegt jetzt doch diese annahme
dazu kämpfen schlussmann einer der
beteiligten forscher dieser stern ins
gut gealtert er sieht heute genauso
aussieht wird seit seiner entstehung von
rund 13,5 milliarden jahren wenn unsere
schlussfolgerung ziehen dass christen
einige dieser massearme sterne eine
zusammensetzung haben wie der des kosmos
direkt nach dem urknall entspricht der
uhr als stern ist aber auch noch in
einer anderen hinsicht eine große
überraschung denn er liegt direkt in
unserer nachbarschaft er kreist um das
zentrum der milchstraße unserer galaxie
diese position des werks sterns wertet
das us forschungsteam als indiz dafür
dass auch andere teile unserer
galaktischen umgebung älter sein müssen
als wir bisher annehmen zudem weckt der
sensationsfund die hoffnung zeitnah mehr
von den lang gesuchten sternen der
ersten generation aufzuspüren modellen
zufolge sind diese aus der ur materie
entstanden die vom urknall stammt die
entstehung dieser sterne der ersten
generation hat das universum und seiner
evolution extrem beeinflusst denn in
ihrem innern haben sich dann wohl alle
schweren elemente gebildet die notwendig
für das leben sind beispielsweise eisen
sauerstoff stickstoff und kohlenstoff
erst dadurch konnten sich
planetensysteme wie das unsrige bilden
und entwickeln doch noch ist dies der
erste stern dieser ersten sterne
generation der gefunden worden ist mit
der entdeckung dieses roten zwerge
steigen jetzt also die hoffnung mehr
davon zu finden und wenn es dazu etwas
neues gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
abonniert dafür am besten auch den
englischen kanal dafür hier klicken
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren und darunter geht es
weiter mit uwe alien messe chen danger
humanity ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal stay tuned viel zu